[Music]
all right we go captain
no matter how many fights you've won
there are still times when it feels like
the world is crashing down on you that's
such a captain voice and on days like
this it actually is
looks like inception this may look like
the s by day but at least I don't have
to face it alone
[Music]
that's
[Music]
that's what's really good really good
[Music]
doctor
[Music]
that was awesome real heroes have each
other's backs
and when the time comes to risk our line
no way we do it side by side
no questions asked look at that that's
awesome
dr. Strange's open it up multiverse
that's awesome
[Music]
no way when it's all full of art
that's when you stand together
we have a plan join us
oh it's not just a fight is a revolution
Wow Wow
that looks amazing for those of you
don't know this is a mobile game coming
for your phone and it's so much better
than I thought it was going to be I
heard about this not too long ago and it
was really looking forward to it and as
you can see here it's pretty awesome I'm
definitely going to be playing it the
multi-verse part of this is it's funny
because obviously we're about to get the
multiverse in the MCU and this is kind
of like leading up to it before phase 4
starts so great timing sure it wasn't
accidental
sure was definitely planned but this
looks fantastic all the different
versions the characters looks pretty
cool we saw a few different versions of
them in there I saw spider-man carrying
a shield at one point bunch of different
versions of spider-man and Doctor
Strange looks awesome so let me know
what you think about this and the
comments down below don't forget to like
the video subscribe of course if you're
new and as always thank you all so much
for watching woof woof